- I know that sometimes
when you're family,
things get heated, cause
I know I'm on The Voice,
okay, we get heated on The
Voice too, all the coach.
We love each other, we're
like brothers and sisters,
- So.
- Yeah right.
- I know, we are, we are,
seriously.
(Simon laughing)
And literally, it kind
of can bleed off stage.
Did y'all ever get in, like
an argument you're like,
you're not coming back from?
Did you ever do that?
(Simon laughing)
- Uh, every hour.
- Well, you came back.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, a lot of them.
- Really?
- I mean I'm not kidding,
every hour.
- A lot of them.
- Wait, why that much?
You're so great together, the chemistry--
- Don't even start with me.
(audience laughing)
- Wait, wait, wait.
- Don't.
- It wasn't my fault.
- You just kept quitting.
(Kelly cackling)
- [Randy] Whoa, whoa.
- That was on the first day.
- Hey, I have been the only
girl in a panel and it is hard.
It's hard to be the only girl.
- Tell me about, tell me--
- She was the only girl, that's true.
- No, and they always use
you as, like the ditzy thing.
- Never, never.
- Oh no, we wouldn't do that!
(all bickering)
- They planned, they planned
the whole live shows around--
- Never, ever, ever.
- No.
- A deer caught in headlights!
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God!
It seems like ya'll are really friendly.
But I do have the, this is my,
actually one of my coolest things,
my connection with you Randy is,
you introduced me to somebody
that changed my life and my career.
And I kind of quasi stole him from Justin.
But somebody here wants to say something
because I have been working
with my musical director,
Jason Halbert, since I dunno,
you put the band together.
And you put him in my path,
(clapping)
and I just wanted to give him a minute,
he wanted to tell you somethin'.
- You probably don't know
this but we met 18 years ago
and you were out with Destiny's Child,
and I was on tour, we were opening up.
And I just wanted a picture
with Beyonce, to be honest.
(laughter)
I knocked on the dressing room door
and walked in the door, I was so nervous.
I hand the camera to
this dude, who was you,
and we talked in the hallway--
- I didn't know this story!
- Afterwards, you asked
me for my phone number.
I gave it to you.
- Yup, really?
(all laughing)
- Cowell, stop it, stop it, stop it!
- And never heard from you, eight months--
(Paula shrieking with laughter)
- [Kelly] This is my favorite!
- Eight months later out of the blue,
I'd just taken another job and
you call me up, and you said,
"I've just finished a show
called American Idol,"
and I called my wife and she's like,
"Take the job," because she'd
been voting for, for Kelly.
But you have no idea how
many cameramen, producers,
people behind the scenes--
- Yeah!
- That they've launched careers for.
- Yes!
(audience cheering)
Randy, you help, you help
and you mentor and you really
like, craft these musicians--
- So annoying.
- And you set them up.
- It's always about
paying it forward, right?
And Jason, I'm so happy to see him here,
I'm happy to see Jessie
here, singing backs!
- [Kelly] Jessie!
(audience clapping)
- Oh my God!
- Is that Jessie singing background?
Hi Jessie.
(Kelly laughing)
I got you the job.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- I love it!
Okay, wait, what are some new
projects you're working on?
- I got this company
called Unify Health Labs,
it's a whole health
wellness kind of company,
they're coming out with
vitamins in the next month.
- Really?
- Look at him!
- Yes!
- Look at Randy!
- We've been doing that--
- Amazing.
- I'm in.
- I still have my
eyewear line that I've
been doing for like,
15 years now, Randy
Jackson Eyewear Collection,
managing--
- Can I put them on?
- Yeah.
- They're actually very hot.
- Managing a ton of writers
and producers and artists and
chefs.
(audience tittering)
- Got a--
- Really?
- You look nice in those.
- Looks good.
(audience cheering)
- You look good in those!
- Randy's eyewear.
- They're like the
glasses anyone can wear.
That's awesome, and also
I wanted to mention,
Paula, we saw each
other at the Billboards.
You couldn't hear us 'cause
you're all out there being
another word I can't say on TV--
(audience cheering)
But, like I was...
When you fell, when you
fell, from the top thing,
I was like, "Who are you
"to still be doing that?"
(Randy chortling)
Like I'm like, I wouldn't do
that now, like you killed it!
- She killed it!
- You made all of us...
And I love it because--
(Kelly drowned out by audience cheering)
- Killed it!
- Thank you!
- Killed it, killed it!
- You did make all of
the artists there go,
"Oh okay, that's how that's done."
Like that was,
(Paula giggling)
it was so great!
So what are you up to right now?
- Well, I have, I just opened
a residency in Las Vegas
at the Flamingo.
- Let's go!
(audience cheering)
- I wanna see that!
- Okay.
- Of course you can,
you guys can come.
- You haven't invited me.
- And you have a, hey mister!
You have like a thousand shows so,
like what are you working on,
well, give me the cliff notes,
what's happening right now,
I know America's Got Talent.
- Yeah, we're doing that.
If I'm being honest with
you, this does make me think,
"If I had one wish, it would be
"to make another show with us again."
- Aw.
- Let's go, man.
- That would be my number one.
- It would be so good!
- Let's go.
- [Kelly] I dare you!
- No, and I'll tell you why,
because apart from the fact
that we had so much fun and,
and look, to credit
you, Kelly, like I said,
we wouldn't be here without you.
The fact that you are...
I mean, and one of the most
successful singers in the world.
And I have to say
something about you, Kelly.
Unlike the majority
you are the same person
off camera--
- Absolutely.
- 100%
- As you are on camera.
(audience cheering drowns out Simon)
You've always respected people,
and you've been very loyal
and you're a great friend
and I'm absolutely thrilled
for you, genuine, you deserve everything,
you've worked hard for it,
and for you, these guys,
even though everyone
remembers all the craziness,
what worked about that series was,
is that Randy, like myself is an A&R guy
but he was also a record producer.
Paula actually was a
brilliant spotter of talent.
I was an A&R guy, you
know, which meant I did it,
which was one of the
reasons why I think we had,
and, and this additional chemistry so,
our legacy genuinely
were, are the artists we,
you know, starting with
you, who we discovered
over like this seven year period and
that's what I'm most proud of.
- A lot of them!
- I mean the show's ratings,
great, that's one thing,
but it's who came through the process
is made it all worthwhile
and that's why genuinely
if I could choose who to
work with all over again,
I would work with these guys again.
(audience cheering)
- I love that!